why do you think it is that the
like government officials these
bureaucrats these politicians
aren't able to understand that guys that
are
like one of the things that drives me
nuts is
i can go and take the risk of buying a
stock pre-ipo
there's one that i bought in that's in
the psychedelics field that i bought at
a
very low entry point i took all the risk
there was no proven
uh you know point that this company was
going to take off
um and they don't have the regulatory
approval uh really to justify
piling money into it but i like the guys
running it i know they've had successful
exits twice
i know that they work hard um and i
believe in
what it is they're doing so i've taken
the risk i can go throw it all in there
and maybe
it turns into a mill or two you know and
i make some serious money off it
um and then the government just comes
along and says oh that's cool i'll just
take half of that now
right you know they've done no work
they've taken no risk and they just take
like
why is it that you think that the
government doesn't get it through their
heads that
guys aren't going to let themselves be
treated like tax cattle over and over
again and redistribute money
in a frivolous fashion like one of the
things that i think was announced since
the g7 summit is justin
justin trudeau mentioned that they're
going to be
distributing vaccines coveted vaccines
to
less fortunate countries at i think
they're spending something like twice
or two and a half times the rate as what
the u.s is
and our population in canada for those
of you that don't know is something like
10 of the us so justin trudeau has
basically
unilaterally decided i'm just going to
take some money
that i've stolen from people and i'm
going to send it outside of the country
to benefit these other people here um
you know so i've got a whole bunch of
problems with that why is it you think
that the government doesn't get that
people that have done work and taken
risks in their lives and
put a dent in the universe aren't going
to let themselves be treated like tax
cattle
because they have allowed themselves to
be treated like tax cattle for too long
and they also it doesn't benefit the
politician
politicians you're only going to be one
vote rich
right there's going to be 99 other votes
you know taxation in the democracy is
kind of like
nine wolves in the sheep voting over
what's for dinner right
uh and and that's the way it is is it
unfair
absolutely so the question is
not whether it's unfair or not the
question is what are you going to do
about it and you have a bunch of
tools that you can use to organize your
life
so that you can say this is the life i
want
i'm going to arbitrage the things i like
whether that's
weather or lifestyle
or infrastructure or
you know a wide variety of things so
that i can
have those things at the
you know at the best possible um
you know a cost to me
and so you know i i don't spend a lot of
time
trying to think about how i'm going to
convince
you know a large population of people
uh to think like i think i'm going to
just spend the time
to recognize that's the way they are and
i'm just going to organize
my life and there's a lot of
opportunities in the modern world
to do that so that their
negativity has a minimum impact on my
life and that of my family
you